michel mais je vais pas y arriver moi
une semaine donne moi moi non non non
moi qui m'a parlé d'un truc c'est un
truc facile qu'on pourrait faire mais
non ça mais de toute façon je peux pas
je vous ai dit 70 euros cette recherche
menée pour trois bouteilles de grands
crus classés en poster ce que vous
faites là découlera à prix cassés six
ans j'avais une carte professionnelle
ah oui très bien je connais non non
c'est des gens sérieux sahraouis
saint-émilion 2007 c'est bien ça non moi
je voulais prendre
attendez je voulais prendre du bon temps
au dessus d'un tiers de garantir le
mollah one pourtant des tiers tu mets
moitié du nombre qui se lit brin trop
dangereuse qui tue effet c'est en
suivant va être tous à la rue [ __ ] tu
te mets dans le crâne ça où l'on me
crache convaincront pour vous tous ces
bouffées sont les commandes à son
habitude pays n'est plus rien boutin ou
flocons [ __ ] en pique aussi
le faire une école à paris et d'écoles
c'est une école de poids faisant tourner
la mer faire le guignol est du
maquillage et tout c'est donc une petit
escroc non parce que c'est comme ça que
tu me vois toi un petit escroc soit je
fais une dépression
[Musique]
m
plat
[Musique]
pas si je vais y arriver
tous en commun le témoin
[Musique]
et donc lui vous le connaissez bien je
crois pas je connais surtout son père